une alliance qui pourrait faciliter une
offensive des insurgés vers la capitale
éthiopienne ce vendredi le front de
libération du peuple du tigré et l'armée
de libération oromo se sont unis à cet
autre groupe indépendantiste provenant
de différentes régions du pays
par le front uni des forces fédéralistes
et confédéraliste éthiopienne le 5
novembre 2021 nous les forces
fédéralistes et confédéraliste
d'ethiopie avant le plaisir d'annoncer
la création d'un front le front uni des
forces fédéralistes et confédéraliste
éthiopienne united front of était open
fédéralistes comme fort
l'objectif de cette union
destitué le gouvernement en place menée
par le premier ministre habib ahmed une
menace sérieuse pourtant balayé d'un
revers de la main par les autorités
gouvernementales
elles démentent une quelconque avancée
des rebelles dans le pays ce conflit ne
doit en aucun cas être traité comme un
engagement entre égaux car le
gouvernement fédéral ait mandaté comme
je le disais par la constitution pour
préserver la paix et la sécurité dans le
pays également je tenais donc à
souligner cet aspect car beaucoup de ces
appels ont tendance à ne pas dénoncer
suffisamment un groupe armé insurgés et
un groupe ou une entité qui a été
désignée comme une organisation
terroriste conformément au processus
constitutionnel et aux lois du pays
depuis quelques semaines le nord du pays
est le théâtre de violents affrontements
entre l'armée gouvernementale et les
rebelles tigréens les indépendantistes
ont récupéré mais quelle est la capitale
de la région avant d'étendre leur
contrôle région d'amhara et d'afar une
perte de terrain considérable pour les
autorités fédérales qui nie ses échecs
le premier ministre éthiopien a décrété
l'état d'urgence sur l'ensemble du
territoire avant d'appeler la population
à s'organiser et à prendre les armes
pour lutter contre l'avancée des
rebelles vers la capitale une sortie
condamnée par les nations unies des
members of the security car sur
les membres du conseil de sécurité ont
exprimé leur profonde inquiétude au
sujet de l'extension et de
l'intensification des affrontements
militaires dans le nord de l'ethiopie
les membres du conseil de sécurité se
sont en outre déclaré gravement
préoccupé par les répercussions du
conflit sur la situation humanitaire en
ethiopie ainsi que sur la stabilité du
pays et de toute la région
depuis le début du conflit la situation
humanitaire ne cesse de s'aggraver dans
le pays aux tigres et 400000 personnes
connaissent la famille pendant qu en
afar et en a marre à ce sont un million
700 mille éthiopiens qui sont confrontés
à une pénurie de nourriture
d'après l'onu